>> Bret: ALL RIGHT.
>> Jesse: THANK YOU.
♪
>> Jesse: FOX NEWS ALERT.
THE REPUBLICANS ARE PROJECTED TO
WIN THE HOUSE.
MEANING NANCY PELOSI WILL NO
LONGER BE THE SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE.
SHE'LL PROBABLY BE THE ITALIAN
AMBASSADOR.
AND IF SHE DOES STICK AROUND,
DEMOCRATS ARE COMING FOR HER
CROWN.
THE HOUSE MARGIN ISN'T AS BIG AS
WE EXPECTED.
REPUBLICANS WILL PROBABLY HAVE
BETWEEN A 5 AND A 10 SEAT
MAJORITY AND KEVIN McCARTHY
WILL BE SPEAKER.
BUT WILL BE FACING SERIOUS
REBELLIONS, THE SENATE IS STILL
IN PLAY NO.
RED WAVE IN THE SENATE.
THE ONLY WAY REPUBLICANS WIN THE
SENATE AT THIS POINT IS IF THEY
WIN NEVADA WHERE REPUBLICAN ADAM
LAXALT IS AHEAD BY ABOUT 23,000
VOTES.
IT LOOKS GOOD THERE.
BUT WE STILL DON'T KNOW.
BUT, THAT MAKES ME A LITTLE
NERVOUS SINCE CLARK COUNTY,
MEANING LAS VEGAS, WILL BE
COUNTING, THEY SAY, FOR DAYS.
SO IT LOOKS LIKE, AGAIN, THIS
COMES DOWN TO A RUN OFF IN
GEORGIA THAT WILL BE IN
DECEMBER, WALKER AND WARNOCK DID
NOT HIT 50%.
A LOT OF THAT HAS TO DO WITH THE
LIBERTARIAN CANDIDATE YOU HAVE
NEVER HEARD OF, THANK YOU CHASE
OLIVER, WHO ATE UP 2% OF THE
VOTE AND MADE IT THAT MUCH
HARDER FOR EITHER CANDIDATE TO
HIT 50.
WHAT A SPOILER.
RON JOHNSON WAS THE WINNER IN
WISCONSIN.
TED BUDD WAS THE WINNER IN NORTH
CAROLINA.
RUBIO WON HIS RACE IN FLORIDA
BIG TIME, CONGRATULATIONS.
BUT DR. OZ LOST TO JOHN
FETTERMAN BY 200,000 VOTES.
BY 3%.
I DID NOT SEE THAT COMING.
ABORTION PLAYED A BIG ROLE IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
IT WAS TOP OF MIND FOR VOTERS AS
THE PRESS SECRETARY WOULD SAY
AND REPUBLICAN VOTERS DIDN'T
SEEM TO TRUST DR. OZ AND AFTER
THAT BRUISING PRIMARY BATTLE, HE
WASN'T ABLE TO PULL IT TOGETHER.
HE WAS A TRUMP PICK SO THAT
HURTS.
AND MITCH McCONNELL DROPPED
ABOUT ALMOST 60 MILLION IN
PENNSYLVANIA HELPING OZ.
AND THAT HURTS, TOO.
THE REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE FOR
GOVERNOR IN PENNSYLVANIA GOT
BLOWN OUT AND THAT ALSO REALLY
HURT OZ.
BUT THE PEOPLE OF PENNSYLVANIA,
THEY WANTED FETTERMAN AND THEY
ARE GOING TO GET JOHN FETTERMAN
FOR SIX YEARS IF HE CAN MAKE IT.
AND THEY ALSO GOT WILL GIVE
FETTERMAN AND THE STONE NOTHING
GATHER THAT TRAVELS AROUND
FETTERMAN AND KEEPS THE COMPUTER
HANDY FOR TRANSLATION.
TELLS YOU THE DEMOCRATS WILL
VOTE FOR ANYBODY AND ANYTHING.
THIS IS BASICALLY LIKE US
AGAINST THEM NOW.
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS COULD
BOTH NOMINATE A GLASS OF ORANGE
JUICE AND DEMOCRATS WILL STILL
SHOW UP.
THEY RAN A SCAM IN PENNSYLVANIA,
TOO.
BECAUSE FETTERMAN HID HIS HEALTH
FOR MONTHS WHILE COVERED FOR
HIM.
REFUSED TO DEBATED OZ UNTIL THE
VERY LAST WEEK WHILE HE HAD
ALREADY BANKED THOUSANDS OF
EARLY VOTES HE DECEIVED THE
VOTERS AND GOT AWAY FROM IT.
THIS EARLY VOTING THING
REPUBLICANS HAVE TO GET A HANDLE
ON.
SHOW UP ON ELECTION DAY AND
DEMOCRATS SHOW UP WEEKS BEFORE
ELECTION DAY DAY AFTER DAY AFTER
DAY THE DEMOCRATIC MACHINE IN
PHILLY AND ALL OVER PENNSYLVANIA
IS GRINDING OUT EARLY VOTES AT A
CRAZY CLIP.
AND COME ELECTION DAY,
REPUBLICANS HAVE A BIG MOUNTAIN
TO CLIMB.
AND UNLESS WE HAVE A GAME PLAN
FOR THESE MAIL-IN BALLOTS AND
EARLY VOTING, THIS IS DEJA VU.
J.D. VANCE WON IN OHIO,
CONGRATULATIONS.
TRUMP ENDORSED HIM.
I LIKE J.D.
BUT McCONNELL HAD TO PLOW
ABOUT $32 MILLION TO HELP J.D.
WIN IN A STATE THAT TRUMP WON BY
8.
THAT MONEY COULD HAVE GONE TO
MASTERS IN ARIZONA.
NOW, MALICE TERSE, OHIO ALSO
LIKE, DIDN'T RAISE ENOUGH DOUGH.
GOT OUTSPENT BY ABOUT A BILLION
DOLLARS A GAZILLION DOLLARS, I
CAN'T KEEP TRACK.
AND GOT DEFINED EARLY BY KELLY'S
MONEY AS KIND OF OUT THERE.
NOW, ARIZONA'S TRICKY.
REPUBLICANS HAVE TO RUN
INDEPENDENT-TYPE GUYS OUT THERE.
IT'S LIKE A McCAIN STATE.
MAVERICK STATE.
SINEMA DOES HER THING OUT THERE.
IT'S WEIRD.
NOBODY CAN EVEN DEFINE WHAT
KELLY BELIEVES IN, BUT IT WORKS.
ALL WE KNOW IS THAT HE IS AN
ASTRONAUT WHO HAS GREAT MANNERS
OR SOMETHING.
McCONNELL SPENT CLOSE TO
$400 MILLION ON THESE SENATE
CANDIDATES.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT GOES ON BEHIND
THE SCENES BUT THAT ASK A LOT OF
MONEY.
WE DIDN'T PICK UP A SINGLE SEAT?
SO, EITHER SOME OF THESE
CANDIDATES ARE GARBAGE OR THE
MONEY IS NOT BEING WELL-SPENT.
BUT TRUMP SITTING ON A MASSIVE
WAR CHEST IN MAR-A-LAGO DID THAT
MONEY GO?
WE DON'T KNOW.
THE GOVERNOR'S RACES WERE ALL
OVER THE MAP.
RON DESANTIS RAN UP THE SCORE IN
FLORIDA WITH A 20-POINT BLOW OUT
WIN.
CONGRATULATIONS.
REPUBLICANS NEVER WIN THAT BIG
IN FLORIDA, EVER.
THE MAN IS SITTING ON A PILE OF
POLITICAL CAPITAL AND HAS A TON
OF MOMENTUM AND WE WILL GET MORE
INTO THAT LATER ON IN THE SHOW.
AND WHAT THAT MEANS FOR THE
PRESIDENTIAL RACE.
WILL LEE ZELDIN IN NEW YORK CAME
REAL CLOSE IN A DEEP BLUE STATE.
ONLY LOST BY A FEW POINTS.
OBAMA, BIDEN, KAMALA THE
CLINTONS ALL HAD TO SWOOP IN AND
SAVE HOCHUL FROM AN UPSET.
AND ZELDIN HAD COAT TAILS.
REPUBLICANS WON A BUNCH OF HOUSE
SEATS IN NEW YORK.
CRIME A MAJOR ISSUE.
STACEY ABRAMS WENT DOWN HARD IN
GEORGIA AND SHE ACTUALLY
CONCEDED THIS TIME.
KEMP WON BY 7 POINTS AND REALLY
OUT PERFORMED HERSCHEL WALKER
WHICH IS GOING TO BE A BIG
PROBLEM IN THE RUNOFF.
STACEY CAN NOW GO BACK TO
WRITING NOVELS AND TEACH AT
2026.
AND BETO O'ROURKE LOST FOR THE
THIRD CONSECUTIVE TIME.
HE HAS NOW LOST A PRESIDENTIAL
PRIMARY, A SENATE RACE AND A
GOVERNOR'S RACE.
HE IS RUNNING OUT OF OFFICES TO
RUN FOR.
AND BETWEEN ABRAMS AND OWE
O'ROURKE, DEMOCRATS HAVE BURNED
NEARLY $200 MILLION.
A LOT OF CHEESE.
AND THAT BRINGS US TO KARI LAKE
WHO IS A NAIL-BITER IN ARIZONA.
>> THERE WAS SOME THEN THAN
GANGS IN MARICOPA COUNTY OR
INCOMPETENCE WE DON'T KNOW.
20% OF VOTING HAD MACHINES THAT
RAN OUT OF INK.
KATIE HOBBS IS THE SECRETARY OF
STATE IN ARIZONA.
SHE IS IN CHARGE OF ELECTIONS.
THERE WAS AN INK SHORTAGE IN
MARICOPA COUNTY.
THE COUNTY THAT DECIDES THE
RACE.
AND THEY WERE SHORT INK.
THE DAY MOST REPUBLICANS VOTE.
ELECTION DAY.
WHERE DID YOU HIDE THE INK,
KATIE?
I'M JUST KIDDING.
I'M SURE IT WAS AN HONEST
MISTAKE.
NOW, LAKE IS DOWN JUST 4,000
VOTES.
BUT THERE'S TONS MORE TO COME IN
AND IT'S BASICALLY A DEAD HEAT
BUT MOST PEOPLE THINK LAKE IS
GOING TO PULL THIS OUT.
NOW, THE EXIT POLLS TELL US A
LOT ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED LAST
NIGHT.
REPUBLICANS ARE MAKING MAJOR
INROADS WITH BLACKS AND LATINOS
AND DOING EVEN BETTER WITH MEN,
SUBURBAN WOMEN AND WORKING
CLASS.
THAT'S NOTHING TO SNEEZE AT.
SO LONG TERM THIS IS FANTASTIC
NEWS FOR THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
BUT DEMOCRATS ARE DOMINATING THE
CITIES.
I MEAN, ABSOLUTE DOMINATIONS, 85
TYPE SPREADS.
SINGLE WOMEN BREAKING FOR
DEMOCRATS BY 30 POINTS.
AND THIS MAKES SENSE WHEN YOU
THINK ABOUT HOW DEMOCRAT
POLICIES ARE DESIGNED TO KEEP
WOMEN SINGLE.
ONCE WOMEN GET MARRIED THEY VOTE
REPUBLICAN.
MARRIED WOMEN, MARRIED MEN GO
FOR REPUBLICANS BY DOUBLE
DIGITS.
BUT SINGLE WOMEN AND VOTERS
UNDER 40 HAVE BEEN CAPTURED BY
DEMOCRATS.
SO WE NEED THESE LADIES TO GET
MARRIED.
AND IT'S TIME TO FALL IN LOVE
AND JUST SETTLE DOWN, GUYS, GO
PUT A RING ON IT.
AND ABORTION IS REALLY DRIVING
TURNOUT.
IN SOME CASES IT DROVE TURNOUT
MORE THAN INFLATION.
SO REPUBLICANS HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT IF THEY ARE FOR A TOTAL
ABORTION BAN OR IF THEY ARE FOR
LEGALIZATION IN THE FIRST
TRIMESTER.
BUT BACK TO THE WOMEN.
THEY ARE ALSO TEACHING OUR
CHILDREN IN SCHOOLS.
SO YOU HAVE HARD CORE DEMOCRAT
FEMALES IN SCHOOL WITH YOUR KIDS
FOR 8 HOURS A DAY.
WE HAVE SEEN THE VIDEOS.
WE HAVE SHOWED YOU WHAT THEY
TEACH IN THOSE CLASSROOMS, TOO.
SO THERE IS A BRAINWASHING
PIPELINE THAT RUNS THROUGH WOMEN
AND CHILDREN AND IT'S STARTING
TO SHOW UP ON ELECTION DAY.
NOW, LOOKING AHEAD IN THE NEXT
TWO CYCLES, THE DEMOCRATS' LUCK
IS PROBABLY GOING TO RUN OUT.
THEY'RE DEFENDING AN INSANE
AMOUNT OF SENATE SEATS AND A LOT
OF THEM ARE IN RED STATES LIKE
MONTANA, OHIO, SO THIS LITTLE
RUN THAT THEY'RE ON IN THE
SENATE, NOT GOING TO LAST
FOREVER.
THE DEMOCRATS LOST THE HOUSE.
AND THE PATH IS OPEN FOR THEM TO
LOSE THE SENATE.
SO, IS JOE BIDEN RUNNING AGAIN?
>> MY INTENTION IS THAT I'M
GOING TO RUN AGAIN.
>> WHAT IN THE NEXT TWO YEARS DO
YOU INTEND TO DO DIFFERENTLY TO
CHANGE PEOPLE'S OPINION OF 9
DIRECTION OF THE COUNTRY,
PARTICULARLY AS YOU CONTEMPLATE
A RUN FOR PRESIDENT IN 2024.
>> NOTHING.
>> Jesse: SO JOE BIDEN LEARNED
NOTHING FROM LAST NIGHT.
75% OF THE COUNTRY SAYS WE ARE
ON THE WRONG TRACK BUT HE IS NOT
GOING TO CHANGE A THING.
EVEN CNN SAYS THAT'S INSULTING.
>> YOU HAVE 75% OF THE COUNTRY
SAYING THAT WE'RE HEADED IN THE
WRONG DIRECTION.
HE SAID HE JUST WOULDN'T DO
ANYTHING DIFFERENT BECAUSE, OF
COURSE, OUR ACHIEVEMENTS TAKE A
LONG TIME TO BE RECOGNIZED.
THAT'S INSULTING PEOPLE.
AND I DON'T THINK THAT WAS A
GOOD ANSWER FROM THE PRESIDENT.
>> Jesse: AND IT LOOKS LIKE
DONALD TRUMP IS ANNOUNCING NEXT
WEEK.
SO IT'S SHAPING UP TO BE ANOTHER
REMATCH.
DOLLS TRUMP WIN?
I HOPE SO.  I LOVE THE GUY.
AND A WEEK AGO I WOULD HAVE SAID
SLAM DUNK.
BUT, AFTER HOW LAST NIGHT SHOOK
OUT, I DON'T KNOW NOW.
DEMOCRATS WILL WALK OVER HOT
COALS TO VOTE AGAINST TRUMP, BUT
WILL REPUBLICANS DO THAT TO VOTE
AGAINST JOE BIDEN?
JOE BIDEN ISN'T THE CLINTONS, HE
IS NOT OBAMA.
HE DOESN'T BRING OUT THE TYPE OF
PASSION AND ANGER THE WAY THESE
OTHER DEMOCRATS HAVE DONE.
REPUBLICANS JUST SEE HIM AS THIS
INCOMPETENT LAZY OLD JOKE.
SO THERE'S NOT A LOT OF EMOTIONS
GOING ON WITH JOE.
BUT THERE ARE AROUND THE COUNTRY
TONIGHT.
YOU CAN'T REALLY CHARACTERIZE
HOW THIS MIDTERM WENT.
ALL THESE RACES WERE DIFFERENT.
ALL THESE CANDIDATES WERE
DIFFERENT.
WE NEED TO RUN EVERY ELECTION
LIKE FLORIDA, DON'T WE?
WE FOUND OUT WHO WON EARLY THAT
NIGHT.
THE VOTE IS SECURE.
WE HAVE CONFIDENCE IN IT, AND WE
DON'T HAVE TO WAIT DAYS TO FIND
OUT WHO WON, WHICH MAK